hello building green
thank you very much for giving me this
opportunity
to talk to you about the new european
bauhaus
when walter gropius set up the original
bauhaus school in 1919
his goal was and i quote
to create a new guild of craftsmen
without the barrier between craftsmen
and
end of quote
when we launched the new european
bauhaus 100 years later
we knew we could aim even higher
because a new generation of architects
designers and engineers already existed
it's you
it's you the building green community
and thousands of others like you
who are reinventing our way of building
and living
back in 1919 the bauhaus movement
brought together form
and function
and explored new methods and new
materials such as steel and concrete
today the new challenge of construction
is
sustainability
and you know this better than anyone
else
you are rediscovering natural materials
such as timber and bamboo
using them to build entire hotels and
even skyscrapers
you are turning buildings from one of
the biggest sources of emissions
into carbon sinks
you have come up with modular
construction systems
that are cheaper than concrete
and which reduce a building's carbon
footprint
by two-thirds
designers are successfully experimenting
with fabrics and mushrooms to replace
co2 and water-intensive leather
production
this is amazing
your work brings together the three
principles
that we have put at the heart of the new
european bauhaus
sustainability
because we all want to protect the
future of our planet
aesthetics
because our soul needs beauty as well as
functionality
and inclusion
because a good life
must be accessible and affordable to
everyone
it is with the three principles in mind
that we have launched the new european
bauhaus
we created it
because we wanted to add a powerful
cultural and artistic dimension to our
european green deal
to make it tangible for people in their
daily lives
what is functional will convince over
time
what is beautiful
will reach hearts in a second
and time is the resource we lack the
most
faced with the crisis of climate change
worldwide buildings account for more
than 40 of our emissions
over half of our waste comes from
construction and demolition
so it is clear that to reach our goal of
climate neutrality by 2050
we must change the way we build and
renovate
my commission's approach
could have been to just set standards
targets and rules to implement the
european green deal
but we knew that this wouldn't be enough
one year ago we started asking ourselves
what is holding people back today
from doing the right thing for the
planet and future generations
at that stage we didn't have many
answers but we knew
that people like you
all around europe and the world
are already exploring new solutions
and defining the new aesthetics of
sustainability
and this is when the concept of the new
european bauhaus
came into play
a movement to unite like-minded people
to generate new collaborations and new
ideas
to bring to a wider public the many
wonderful things being done by pioneers
like you
to give a face to the growing desire for
change
to accelerate the transition to a more
sustainable way of living and doing
businesses
and that's why the natural first step
was to reach out to architects academics
artists
designers and engineers
through a six-month co-design phase
a moment when everybody could contribute
to shaping the new european bauhaus
i knew that we would receive many good
ideas but i have to admit that i did not
expect
such a huge reaction
the response from your community was
overwhelming
we received over 2 000 contributions
from every corner of europe and beyond
it was a true explosion of creativity
and the breath of fresh air for our
european institutions
now
as a result
we have a clear concept and roadmap for
the new european bauhaus
the contributions we received
highlighted
four clear priorities for action
first
reconnect with nature
it's part of who we are as human beings
and it is essential for our health
both physical
and mental
second regain a sense of belonging
in the best european tradition
cities are built on a human scale
they are made for people not machines
people should feel that they are part of
a community
and successful livable cities are built
on vibrant communities
third
prioritize places and people in need
fragile households need sustainable
solutions more than anyone else
clean energy and energy efficiency
reduce the burden of rising gas prices
and every year 800 000 social houses
need renovation
this is precisely where we must bring in
sustainability
beauty
and inclusion
my fourth point
refocus on the life cycle of buildings
and materials
i know how much you care about this
many of you are already bringing the
circular economy into the construction
sector
with bio-based or recyclable materials
or by prioritizing renovation over
construction
it's now that we must decide what kind
of buildings we want to leave to the
next generation
i hope that you will agree
just how much your principles overlap
with ours
and how much potential for cooperation
we have
so let me be very practical
we have already launched the first calls
for proposal under the new european
bauhaus
more will follow in the coming months
we have set aside 85 million euros in
funding for this year and 2022
some of the calls concern large-scale
interventions
others are targeted to startups and
citizens initiative
it is a call to all of you to shine with
your ideas
and in parallel
we are creating a new european bauhaus
lab a place to connect people and to
fast-track good projects
to give an example
the lab will work on developing a new
european bauhaus label
for projects that share our principles
and it will look into european and
national legislation
to address any obstacle that prevent
people and companies from building green
in all of this
your engagement will make a difference
in the preparatory phase we already saw
some valuable contributions for example
from denmark
i would now like to invite all of you to
get involved and to make change happen
on the ground
and let me conclude where i started
with the original bauhaus
born a century ago
the greatest responsibility of the
architect and planner i believe
is the protection and development
of our habitat
these are not my words
again
they are the words of walter gropius 100
years ago
and this idea is what still brings us
together today
so thank you very much and keep on
building green